Our Community Spaces and Places - Ō Tātou
Wāhi
Our district is growing, so there are more people wanting to use our community spaces and places.
Right now, the Council provides 34 community
buildings, including swimming pools, libraries,
town halls and service centres.
The council also provides about 1,000 hectares of
extensive park and reserve space
including neighbourhood parks,  sports parks,
public gardens, and cultural
heritage sites.
These are really important in supporting community
health and wellbeing,
and in attracting residents, businesses and events to our district.
We need to plan well for the future
and think about what community facilities
and open spaces we need for our growing population.
Our District, Our Future - Waimakariri 2048 aims to:
So what do you think?
Let us know your thoughts and find out more
about the District Development Strategy at
waimakariri.govt.nz